Man, I am not able to understand, I am not able to do any more revision, I am
not able to manage my time
or this is the same for me, I mean I am
not able to sit for long hours, I sit for half an hour and
then get up, this means I am
not studying for long hours.  Sir, what has happened, sir, our
time management is not happening
regarding studies. Sir, the same thing is happening, that is, we are
not feeling interested in any subject. I don't know
why this is happening. See, children have so many
excuses for not being able to study.  There are also
problems due to which they
feel worried, everyone has the same reason,
not raising questions, raising questions at home is not possible, do
n't fight too much, go and ask,
yes, when you ask, there will be a fear of forgetting, so
you will have to ask again and again for 7 days 10.  Will revise once a day,
everything will be sorted,
no problem,
sir.